BRIAN: LATEST STAY-AT-HOME ORDER
IS IN EFFECT AND SPARKING FURY
AMONG GOLDEN STATE RESIDENTS,
DEPUTIES WILL NOT ENFORCE THE
SHUTDOWN.
MATTER OF PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
NOT LAW ENFORCEMENT AND NOW NOT
LAW ENFORCEMENT SAYING HIS
ACTIONS ARE IN LINE WITH THE
CONSTITUTION, THAT SHERIFF JOINS
US NOW.
SHERIFF, WHAT BROUGHT YOU TO
THIS CONCLUSION?
>> WELL, THERE’S SO MANY FACTORS
THAT GO INTO IT BUT IT’S BEEN A
LONG YEAR FOR EVERYBODY.
WE KNOW THAT.
IT’S BEEN VERY IMPACTFUL UPON
ALL OF THE BUSINESSES AND
RESIDENTS OF ORANGE COUNTY AND
CALIFORNIA.
BUT I JUST DON’T THINK THAT IT’S
SOMETHING THAT FALLS IN LINE
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT PRIORITY.
WE HAVE MANY OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT WE ARE
DEALING WITH, MANY
RESPONSIBILITIES REALLY AREN’T
OURS THAT WE ARE DEALING,
HOMELESSNESS, SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER, IT’S NOT ONLY UNFAIR
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT I DON’T
THINK IT’S FAIR AND STANDS THE
CONSTITUTIONAL TEST.
BRIAN: I DON’T KNOW HOW IT’S
LIKE IN YOUR COUNTY, WHEN I RUN
IN RESTAURANT, I SEE PLEXIGLASS,
SOCIAL DISTANCING, TABLES
SEPARATING, VOLUNTARY LESS
CAPACITY.
THESE OWNERS WANT TO COMPLY.
ARE YOU NOTICING THE SAME THING?
>> WE ARE NOTICING EXACTLY THAT.
EVERY ONE OF THE BUSINESSES THAT
ARE OPERATING HAVE MET
EXPECTATIONS OF THE STATE.
THE STATE HAS COME OUT AND SAID
THAT IF YOU NEED TO -- IF YOU
WANT TO CONTINUE OPERATING AS A
BUSINESS YOU HAVE TO DO THESE
THINGS.
IT’S LIKE THE GOLD -- GOAL POSTS
KEEPS MOVING WEEK BY WEEK.
I HEARD THE STORY THAT YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER ABOUT IN LOS
ANGELES WHERE A LADY HAD A TENT
AND OPERATING IN PARKING LOT AND
THEY CAN OPERATE AND SHE CANNOT.
I DON’T KNOW HOW YOU CAN HAVE
DISPARAGED RULES AND EXPECT
PEOPLE TO FOLLOW THEM.
IF THEY FOLLOW THOSE, THEY ARE
IN ESSENCE PUTTING THEMSELVES
OUT OF BUSINESS, THEIR
LIKELIHOOD IS GONE.
>> WHAT BOTHERS ME OF PEOPLE IN
YOUR PROFESSION, YOU ARE GOING
THROUGH ENOUGH, THE COPS ARE THE
BAD GUY AND IT’S YOUR FAULT AND
YOU HAVE TO GO TO LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS AND TELL THEM THEY
CAN’T EARN A LIVING, THE TIMING
COULDN’T BE WORSE, NOT ONLY THE
MISSION.
>> THAT’S PART OF THE ISSUE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS YEAR FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AFTER
MINNEAPOLIS AND THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE MADE ITS MISSION TO
DEFUND THE POLICE, CHANGE THE
RULES TO COME OUT WITH NEW
LEGISLATION AND RESTRICT WAY WE
CAN DO OUR JOB.
ON THE ONE HAND, WE WANT YOU TO
STOP DOING THINGS TO RESULT IN
ACTIONS FOR THE COMMUNITY BUT
NOT THIS TIME, RULES ARE
DIFFERENT AND GO OUT AND ARREST
PEOPLE.
I’M NOT SURE THAT WE WANT TO BE
IN A POSITION THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OPERATING WITH THAT
MISSION IN MIND TO GO OUT AND
ARREST LAWFUL RESIDENTS OF THE
COUNTY WHO ARE TRYING TO MAKE
ENDS MEET AND ARE DOING SO BY
FOLLOWING THE RULES.
THE RULES CAN’T CHANGE WEEK BY
WEEK AND IT’S BEEN DIFFICULT FOR
OUR CONSTITUENTS IN ORANGE
COUNTY, THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
THE NATION QUITE HONESTLY TO
KEEP REDEFINING THE WAY WE
OPERATE.
BRIAN: SHERIFF, NO DOUBT ABOUT
IT.
HOPEFULLY NO RETRIBUTION FROM
SACRAMENTO.
SHERIFF, THANK YOU AND HAVE A
GREAT HOLIDAY.